bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
où on va beaucoup parler de l'angleterre
à travers deux événements le break site
nom qui était votée jeudi par les
anglais et puis et puis c'est quand même
un peu de l'angleterre que ça d'où vient
de golf puisque puisque ben l'open de
france commence au la fin de la semaine
prochaine et pour en parler va nous
sommes ravis et heureux d'accueillir
quelqu'un qui voit là qu'il faut être
très occupés sexuellement tôt puisque
vous êtes le directeur du golf national
c'est paul armitage
alors on est ravi de vous recevoir
évidemment pour l'open de france mais
aussi parce que vous êtes anglais est
aujourd'hui tf1
voilà vous avez voté depuis ce matin à
voter jeudi on enregistrait vendredi le
lendemain du vote
comment c'est quoi votre sentiment
aujourd'hui un peu de gueule de bois
ah oui gueule de bois évident fatigue
parce que je me suis couché
c'était tout bon je me suis réveillé à 5
heures pour regarder en direct la bbc on
sait en fait sky news et ça nous voulu
bon du tout donc je reviens vous vous
êtes dit contre le brésil
absolument je suis un européen
je reproduis européens d'ailleurs parce
que si je parle comme ça français c'est
que je suis là depuis longtemps mais je
suis sans qu'on semble 25 ans maintenant
et en france tout à fait j'ai fait tout
mon éducation jusqu'à l'âge de 20 ans
vin en angleterre et puis voit alors
florence mercadé choqué avocate au
barreau de versailles glisse vannes où
mustapha ould mah ce match à fond
d'accent anglais président du
football-club de et de comment s'appelle
l'association des pharmacies pharmacies
doyen ainsi qu'une association en
l'occurrence voilà qui fait du tir école
du matériel médical pour la
redistribution mais ses vents une
association de loi 1901 rien à voir avec
les officines c'est bien ça c'est bien
distincts des deux je le précise mme c
pharma citoyens pharma citoyens j'avais
juste une remarque pour notre ami elle
est allée de gueule de bois
en l'occurrence est ce que vous parlez
des clubs ou non n'a pas de remarques
comme ça il va boire et faire cesser et
puis on a une troisième raison de parler
de l'onglet c'est des anglais c'est que
ils ont inventé le football et online
l'angola pourra parler de l'euro est
évidemment auquel vous avez système pas
mal de mal si vous aidez encore un
système de nos matches d'ici la finale
et puis cela soit dix militaires dont
jour qui n'a pas la gueule de bois parce
que vous êtes vous plutôt je vous étiez
plutôt pour le break 6 me semble-t-il
oui non surtout pour la démocratie pour
le respect des gens qui votent
normalement sans avoir un couteau sous
la gorge et je trouve ça respectable
voilà donc fait après on va parler mais
je ne faisais rien de choquant là c'est
pas honteux d'avoir voté pour la sortie
du tube alors c'est peut-être dommage
mais je respecte les gens qui votent et
et qui s'exprime donc c'est bien alors
première question comment tourne vers
vous alors vous avez vu à ça évidemment
depuis depuis la france veut dire mais
est-ce que vous avez été surpris par le
par le parent le vote est ce que vous
attendiez à ce vote là où ce que c'était
tellement indécis que vous pouvez pas
savoir non pas surpris parce que c'est
parce que je voulais donc gré quand on
n'obtient pas ce dernier moment on
espère voilà exactement exactement donc
il ya cette déception là par contre ça
fait 40 ans qu'on est un pied dedans un
pied dehors on sait jamais très très
clair vu du côté français c'est toujours
bravo dépôts dont dedans et c'est donc
on a toujours eu cette sensation de des
britanniques parce que c'est pas
uniquement les anglais et les écossais
des gallois et non on va en parler parce
que j'ai quand même pas les mêmes
réactions - exactement exactement donc
d'un point de vue britannique
ça jamais été super super clair ce que
je trouve décevant aujourd'hui c'est que
dans ce référendum en a donné deux choix
c'est soit on veut rester impuni dans un
ou deux heures c'est à dire que ce que
je trouve dommage de la part des
britanniques c'est de ne pas avoir saisi
l'opportunité de dire écoutez ça nous
satisfait pas parce que ça bouge pas ou
c'est une douceur assez bruxelles c'est
c'est ce qu'on reproche à l'europe c'est
un peu c'est un peu trop lente
on n'est plus dans une pays démocratique
qui bouge qui fait de pas d'avant et un
en arrière mais on avance quand même est
ce que je reproche c'est que les anglais
n'ont pas pris le truc en disant voilà
il ya ces deux options là mais a
peut-être un troisième c'est d'aller
dire se plaindre dire voilà mais voilà
notre vision voilà qu'est ce qu'on
voudrait voir leurs amis oui mais voilà
notre vision encore pas très vite tomber
quelques mois mais ils ont tenu eux
mêmes oui ils sont pas venus avec un
projet européen l'europe en disant que
le modèle autres le modèle autres c'est
ça et si vous n'êtes pas en phase ben là
on va faire notre ferme pour sortir
c'est ça que je reproche c'est vrai que
mes cd reproche qu'on peut faire
peut-être tous les gouvernants européens
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont toujours
considéré l'europe en fonction des
intérêts de leur propre nation mais
jamais avec une vision globale avec une
vision européenne d'aider des choses sbc
le cas des anglais évidemment alors
peut-être plus fortement que les autres
et on se souvient de la phrase de
marianne h he was my money back
c'était les femmes et messieurs prenez
au fond l'ailé depuis quelques années en
tout cas les dirigeants européens
c'est vrai qu'il voit d'abord l'intérêt
immédiat de leur nation avant de voir
l'intérêt européen est ce qu'on pouvait
espérer aussi une europe
aussi idéal que ça à 28 c'était ça aussi
la bêtise voilà donc c'est non mais il y
alors il ya évidemment des problèmes
européens on va pouvoir y revenir je
reviens quand même à ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que c'est le
royaume uni qui a voté et on voit des
différences considérables
c'est à dire que l'ecosse vote à 63%
contre le breakbeat l'irlande du nord
contre aussi à 56% à peu près enfin et
que les gallois et les anglais
il égalerait les sachant que 60 % des
londoniens et ça c'est important parce
que notre prochain premier ministre
peut-être ses lambris dorés on va
arrêter pour rester dans leur présente
je veux dire c'est assez complexe la
situation un événement il doit avoir une
personne qui est mal assis sur son sens
où ça trône je sais pas vous voyez les
activités à la jane birkin à longue
langue française quand c'est un anglais
qui parle c'est la reine parce que elle
va se voir je pense avoir un éclatement
ou au moins une tentative une nouvelle
tentative de les écossais dans des
allées par les écossais anglais elle va
les irlandais eux aussi ils voient les
femmes désirent mandela s'est très tôt
ce matin ont dit qu'ils vont demander
officiellement à faire un homme aussi
pour quitter parce que ils veulent pas
voir mes draps entière bah oui
aujourd'hui a pas de frontières dont
l'irlande du nord et l'irlande l'air y
en a pas parce que les deux sont dans la
communauté européenne demain l'irlande
du nord va être extraits par ou sortie
par
la grande bretagne ça veut dire qu'il ya
une mise en place de frontières eux ils
ont pas je pense là envie de revenir à
quelque chose de barrières ils ont déjà
vécu exactement
et donc je trouve tout à fait légitime
qu'il ya cette réflexion donc là le
royaume uni ce changera rien à leur
problème de frontière
s'ils sont pas contents de ce qu'on va
remettre une frontière de kits de de
devenir indépendant ne lèvera pas cette
frontière donc non c'est l'union c'est
l'union des deux irlande ligneuse adoré
elana classe et sa ville et la sortie il
y a dix ans parlait pas du tout d'une y
en a au contraire a toujours pas avec
schengen etc
vous avez raison de dire la reine se
trouve dans une position compliquée
parce qu'elle n'a pas le droit
d'intervenir dans le débat et en même
temps elle est la garante de l'union de
du royaume uni donc c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué enfin cédé dans une position
très difficile à obtenir est dans une
position difficile que c'est elle qui
perçoit le plus de subventions de
l'europe au niveau de l'agriculture puis
ce qu'elle perçoit pour tous et châteaux
etc sera à peu près de 2 millions
d'euros par an et donc il disait il y
avait toute une émission mais des
missions là dessus qu'ils disaient que
les grandes perdantes d'ibrix il s'était
quand même la reine d'angleterre qu'elle
est perdue
mais si à titre personnel des
subventions pour l'entretenir
alors on mesure pas encore évidemment
les conséquences de ce vote on va les
voir very voir d'abord des négociations
qui peut tirer jusqu'à jusqu'à deux ans
donc ça va être long mais comme ça
intuitivement
les envois sais pas vous mais quelle
qu'elles sont à votre avis les
conséquences de ce vote pour les anglais
bon pour au niveau économique etc
je pense qu'il y aura une période de
turbulences mais y aura pas beaucoup de
risques en connaît d'autres pays qui
sont marche de l'europe comme la suisse
ou autres qui vivent bien et
l'angleterre d'ailleurs une économie je
pense pas assez je pense assez solides
pour il va y avoir des départs
il faut penser aux trois cent mille
français qui habite à londres
qu'est ce qu'ils deviennent est ce
qu'ils vont tous pouvoir rester ainsi de
suite dont il ya plein de questions qui
viennent
à l'esprit en ce moment mais je pense à
moyen terme et long terme que l'impact
sera assez c'est neutre parce que les
anglais ils ont fait ils ont fait leur
avancement tout seul en même en étant en
europe
ils ont toujours la livre ils ont pas et
son plancher une gaine des choses comme
ça donc je pense que les conséquences
gravissimes quand on a voulu nous mettre
minutes et de haine
nous n'aurons pas nécessairement lieu et
puis on regarde les bourses aujourd'hui
la bourse qui dévisse le moins c'est
lequel nous allons assez hallucinant la
livre a dévissé mais on est content
quelque part pour se croire plus
d'export mais non vous pouvez que vous
allez lire au moins en vacances à
l'étranger
vas y avait traité en france sont pas
très heureux non non ça c'est une perte
de pouvoir d'achat est ce que justement
alors il faudra regarder plus plus
finement la composition des votes mais
on s'aperçoit au gros que les personnes
âgées ont voté plus tôt pour l'aubrac
dit les jeunes plutôt plutôt contre et
au fond on arrivé à une situation assez
intéressante c'est dire que les plus
âgés qui ne connaît trop bas
les conséquences de ce vote d'avenir ont
bloqué une situation que les autres vont
vous vivrez peut-être est donc peut-être
ils vont souffrir non ça je pense qu'il
ya est justement tu as fait raison c'est
une affinage moi j'ai fait de l'erasmus
compte
en 1989 j'ai fait une année
universitaire en échange d'une année en
france et donc je suis vraiment plus
européen parce que c'était la première
année dernière la première année donc
j'ai tout foirer à l'université de
bourgogne et j'ai pas en nous le dira on
m'a mis dans la loi un truc que je
connais de langues étrangères appliquées
12 uv à faire j'en ai réussi un c'était
l'anglais merveilleusement bien
ça c'est vous a semblé bien parce qu'il
est j'ai passé une année formidable et
c'était ça l'idée de l'europe en plus
c'était de d'échanger des faits
exactement exactement exactement dans
mon âge moi je suis pour leur emploi est
encore plus jeune parce que ces choses
là on était ancré mais mes parents mes
parents oui je peux pas vous dire
aujourd'hui les 200 ans vit en
angleterre je peux pas vous dire comment
ils ont voté mais je pense qu'ils n'ont
pas la même vision même hayon et même si
elle fait son arrivée on va lancer en
disant bon on s'en fout bon c'est mme
bahia il ya quand même le côté insulaire
tant que je joue dans un value imaginer
aussi sainte et qu'est ce que les uns
les autres comment vous les expliquer
peut-être ce vote et comment vous le
vivez vous plutôt sympathique parce que
ça ne peut que redonner non mais
économiquement face je veux dire je
pense que c'est un problème qui est plus
anglais que français nous en france on
voit pas du tout on n'en verra pas
beaucoup d'inconvénients je pensais mais
après je pense que c'est un coup de pied
salutaire dans la fourmilière européenne
parce que grâce à ce choc ça va
peut-être poussé les dirigeants des pays
européens à se dire attention si les
anglais sont partis avec ce nombre de
voix quelqu'un de considérable entre les
pour et les contre r c'est quand même
c'est plus qu'un signe à ses quelque
chose il faudrait vraiment que les
choses changent maintenant ben voilà
laissons pas le danemark sandales ailées
sont pas tous les autres pays qui vont
se dire à peu les anglais sont partis le
pays n'a pas coulé le lille n'est pas
inondée voilà on peut y aller donc il va
falloir que que l'europe un peu plus
intelligente et un peu plus vrai qu'elle
a dû dire ça oui mais non mais voilà
donc
c'est ça aussi avec blaine sont allés et
surtout ne critiquons pas les anglais
que je tout on peut tout à fait
comprendre et c'est pas qu'un problème
je pense de deux d'âge etc
c'est que je pense qu'aussi c'est un
terme qui vous aimez pas mais c'est
aussi un problème d'identité je pense
qu'on peut aussi être content être fiers
de se dire voilà mon pays' je le vois
qui disparaît je vois on voit beaucoup
de reportages sur ces espaces au
danemark où les danois sont absolument
terrorisée à l'idée de tout ce qui fait
de l'identité du danemark est en train
de se se déliter complètement et
deviennent de plus en plus anti européen
uniquement à cause de ça c'est pas des
trucs économique la plus belle il
savourait sont des sensations ça va nous
jouer des gens qui me disent on va se
replier faire au mam mais c'est pas faux
ce cas là on n'en fait pas forcément ça
va pas dire se replier sur canal que
goeman on peut pas non plus tout laisser
filer mais comme un repli sur soi que
les onglets sont extrêmement d'ailleurs
la campagne était très violente
on sait bien que les anglais sont un
peuple extrêmement ouvert et je veux
dire aucune crainte sur le repli sur soi
de l'angleterre
franchement oui et puis encore une fois
arrêtons ce jour de penser que des c'est
ça que c'est la mort de l'europe
la dernière fois qu'on avait fait un
vote en france se dire tout le monde
avait voté non et du coup on n'a même
pas tenu compte de ce nouvel appel aux
côtés des gens et non après pour leur
faire voter oui alors je dirais si c'est
une catastrophe est là pour une fois et
les gens sont exprimés et tant mieux ça
va je partage avec jean charles est ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure sur le fait
qu' effectivement il ya eu un vote
la démocratie s'est exprimée et on doit
la respecter tous tout en respectant
bien évidemment leur choix et il est
vrai que concernant les anglais voilà
c'est arrivé il ya quelques heures on a
l'information depuis ce matin et on est
devant un bouleversement et en même
temps on peut rassurer les anglais comme
on peut rassurer toise de la planète ça
va continuer ça va continuer les
échanges ont continué le commerce va
continuer bref sauf que quand on prend
une décision comme celle là moi je pense
que les anglais ont pris en tout cas
pour la majorité de ceux qui ont voté
pour la sortie ils ont pris cette
décision
en pensant que ça irait mieux pour
l'angleterre sinon c'est pas la peine de
voter et en l'occurrence ceux qui
voulaient pas le break site c'était pour
dire on doit rester en europe pour le
bien-être de notre notre pays donc moi
je considère que c'était pas la bonne
décision
elle été prise on la respecte cela étant
voilà l'angleterre va continuer les
échanges probablement bilatéraux
angleterre europe il ya d'autres options
qui sont qui sont prévues qui sont à
construire mais vous disiez tout à
l'heure que effectivement il est
peut-être stratégiquement quelque chose
à faire c'est à dire faire peser sur
l'europe
la sortie de l'angleterre et non pas
faire part de faire ce faire peser sur
la moitié du peuple anglais cette sortie
qui pourrait encore une fois avoir des
conséquences pour tout le monde mais
quand jean charles dit finalement pas de
conséquences pour la france pas de
conséquence pour le monde si parce que
les économies sont tellement maintenant
imbriquées les unes dans les autres
un exemple simple qui peut qui vient à
mon avis peu va parler c'est que les
anglais et la place financière en
particulier
voilà une expertise à toute épreuve
qu'on a laissé d'ailleurs aux anglais
faire sauf que la majorité des fonds qui
sont gérés par les places financières
anglaises sont des fonds européens
est ce que la loi change en rien notre
souveraineté cette fois ci parce qu'on
parle de souveraineté tout le temps on
parle d'identité de souveraineté là il
ya déjà probants premières places
financières doit sur génome la bourse
pas celle de l'angleterre les bourses
mondiales effectivement on pourrait dire
que demain il ya peut-être à faire gérer
les fonds européens par des européens
mais il ya d'autres conséquences à ça
voilà les conséquences elles existent
mais la loi des vases communicants
existe aussi sévère cure a dû plus y
aura du moins tous les experts
s'accordent à dire que globalement ça
sera un peu ça sera un petit peu
un petit peu dégradée en termes
d'économies mais mais pas plus que ça
cela étant moi je reste un européen
convaincu
pour moi il n'y a pas d'autre solution
que d'aller vers l'europe à 28 alors à
27 maintenant et non pas à la réduire
encore plus parce que justement le ch et
maintient que si on est nombreux
l'union fait la force alors si on
commence à défendre qu'à l'europe alors
si on veut juste étudie un tout petit
peu je pense que par exemple l'idée
depuis 10 ans qu'il essayait de sortir
comme épouvantail la turquie en dix ans
la turquie va venir en europe je pense
que c'est aussi pour ça que c'est voter
parce que je voulais c'est une idée de
l'europe qui est quand même pas la
langue de plus bien des endroits
rockland et c'est vrai que le problème
de l'immigration domination européenne
notamment qui est arrivée en masse en
angleterre 1 notamment notamment la
france la france il faut des données 350
londres mais ces images y sont bloqués à
quai sont pas des chômeurs migrants sont
les travailleurs qui sont bloqués par le
par le fait de la france ça veut dire
que demain cette vague migratoire qui
étaient bloqués dont les patients dans
les terres ils sont pas bloquées par le
fait de la france sont bloqués à la
demande de l'anglais hiver par les
français
on sait ce que c'est un accord s'était
c'était le souk arabe placenta jetons
l'asie qu'ont les responsables font la
responsabilité d'empêcher voilà je vous
propose éclaté dans une première
réaction c'est celle de pierre lequiller
qui est député des yvelines et qui est
un européen convaincu membres du parti
républicain et sa première réaction au
vote des anglais je suis révolté parce
que françois hollande a été complètement
inactif pendant quatre ans sur les
questions européennes et
ils proposent tous d'un seul coup
d'aller rencontrer madame merkel pour
parler de l'approfondissement d'euros
s'il ya longtemps qu'il aurait pris
alors la cci il fait poser là une des
responsabilités sur sur le président
français sur françois hollande
y a pas fondamentalement temps on a un
peu l'impression quand même que que tout
le monde découvre ce résultat ce matin
sans jamais l'avoir envisagé alors que
quand on propose un référendum on peut
quand même se douter il ya ce n'était
pas un vote avec 12 soit possible
c'était oui c'était non donc je pense
que c'est gouverner c'est prévoir et là
je veux voir ce matin hollande qui a
réuni un comité de crise n'ont pas où il
est mais qu'est ce qui se passe venaient
tous autour de moi président du sénat
s'est fait en dix matches des recettes
sont des débuts qu'ils avaient commencé
déjà à travailler sur la sortie de
l'angleterre a déjà depuis depuis pour
un peu peur ce matin qu'on en a dit
françois hollande va réunir michel sapin
jean marc ayrault et même désir pour
sauver leurs familles réunis en cette
journée historique
ce sont clairement il ya clairement la
relation très proche et c'est notre
faute c'est la faute des anglais aussi
de ne pas avoir pénétré ça mais le
couple franco allemand oui en disant que
ok bah on est en marche parce qu'on a un
pied en pierre
dedans on pas dedans c'est un peu notre
faute qu'on n'y est pas parce qu on ne
peut pas inviter à tous et on n'est pas
invité à parler de tout et mais au delà
on aurait dû ou l'angleterre aurait dû
proposer autre chose c'est ça que je
suis en train de dire maintenant au lieu
de dire si nous marchons est proposé
si ça vous cette visite surtout une
autre sortie des onglets comme boulot
aussi
les anglais commençent à aussi est assez
bizarrement j'avais pas pensé à ça comme
une fermeture d'une chapitre sur les
guerres aussi sur les télévisions
anglaises ils disent voilà l'europe va
profondément changer après ce que vous
avez dit que c'est peut-être le coup le
coup de pied là où il fallait pour
bouger et changer un peu la façon de
gérer l'europe avec les leaders des
choses comme ça et de faire autrement
l'europe
les anglais partent mais c'est peut-être
le moyen de dire ok rassembler c'est
bien mais uniquement pour qu'on soit
tous des amis c'est peut-être pas bon
non plus non mais là disait difficulté
vrai que c'est que notre page de
l'histoire qui se dit non mais depuis
des années on n'a pas fait en sorte de
réunir les gens autour d'un programme
politique d'un pouvoir économique
d'essayer d'avoir une harmonisation
sociale fiscale tous anna blight voulait
pas les pays non plus il aurait fallu
pour qu'on arrive à avoir la joie
errance entre tous les pays je crois
qu'on est en ligne avec catherine
chatignoux québec aurait été envoyée
spéciale des échos un londres et donc en
direct de londres
bonjour bonjour alors comment comment
vous êtes promenés au long de ce post va
pas comment vous avez les anglais qui
sont ils sont tous un peu on est tous un
peu tout sur les anglais comme comme les
européens en général je pense que les
les gagnants finalement les partisans du
vif
ceux qui voulaient quitter l'europe sont
les plus d'étonner peut-être parce que
même si les sondages disaient que il y
avait quand même que ce serait très
serrée qu'elle rencontre très serrée
personne n'y croyait vraiment on pensait
pas que finalement les britanniques que
franchiraient le pas qu'au dernier
moment dans l'ue au devant l'urne
hésiterait et corrupteur de
l'incertitude a quand même été un des
grands sujets de la campagne
donc en fait
je crois quand même on était étonnés de
leur audace et qui je crois que ça
révèle vraiment des divisions qui te
sont fait jour pendant la campagne qui
était très dur et ça révèle plusieurs
divisions au sein de la société
britannique entre les jeunes qui sont
très pro-européens les vieux qui sont
pas du tout entre les classes évidemment
les perdants ceux qui sont ceux qui se
considèrent comme les laissés pour
compte comme les perdants quand même de
deux organisations de l'ouverture et
puis aussi une division entre notre
entre les différentes régions entre une
angleterre quand même très à part
londres
très pro propres aubry et puis à l'école
ce qui a voté très facilement pour le
maintien pour les matières les
conséquences alors il y a des
conséquences sur la politique anglaise
évidemment c'était d'émissions de
carbone seront parle de boris johnson
pour le pour le remplacer quitté
l'ancien maire de londres qui était pour
le brésil mais quelles conséquences
aussi pour l'europe est ce qu'on peut la
mesure déjà il va y avoir un sommet la
semaine prochaine à bruxelles
mais est-ce que ça suffit on vérifie non
la conséquence immédiate est que il
faillit médiane finalement c'est pas
évident tout ça va se faire pendant des
mois mais il va falloir divorcé et à
dire que tous ses liens avec les liagre
ont été noués depuis des années entre le
royaume uni et l'europe il va falloir
les faire comme quand on divorce niveau
voilà l'erreur supprimer les contrats
rendre l'argent qui est critiquée au
budget cette année
récupéré par rapatrier les agences de
européennes qui sont sur le sol
britannique
virez les eurocrates la britannique
becky dont il voulait donc s'il ya
besoin d'un petit palais à bruxelles qui
était honni oui mais il faut il faut il
se bat pour toi ça va prendre deux ans
ça peut aller plus vite
ça va prendre du temps parce que je ne
vois pas les choses se passaient très
bien votre être très compliqué les
marcheurs l'europe qui voudraient ça se
passe bien et vite pour renouer des
liens privilégiés avec l'angleterre et
ce qui peut être comme la france
seul pack n'a pas trop bien parce que ça
pourrait donner des idées à d'autres qui
en europe aimerait aussi au fond faire
un peu le chantage et obtenir des
conditions particulières donc ça va
jouer comme ça entre avoir aussi qui va
prendre gouvernement qui va négocier
c'est pas cameron se fera consulteurs
selon sa personnalité
le divorce fera plus ou moins
acrimonieux comme dans les couples
c'est boris johnson ça risque d'être un
crime odieux en même temps c'est un
pragmatique 1 c'est le même qu'il ya
quelques années j'ai entendu récemment
inventait le la vision de la turquie et
se demander pourquoi on a assisté au
temps pour dire que l'europe est un
continent très bien donc elles un homme
qui est capable la ville a changé d'avis
assez vite
merci infiniment et donc je rappelle que
vous êtes là l'envoyé spécial des échos
alors on voit que te passer au golf non
à baconnes vous dire non à commentaires
là dessus
non juste pour terminer dire que la
norvège ce à une économie florissante
elle n'est pas dans l'europe la suisse
s'en sort pas si mal
la suisse et la norvège désaccord non
trade contraignant avec nos robes mais
on peut aller en norvège à tous et la
norvège accepte même de faire les 3% de
déficit mais elle accepte de toutes les
règles de l'europe centrale à voir mais
la contrepartie est mixé par forcément
question dans ces notes se situer sur
cette partie des quatre des quatre
systèmes suite à des actes peuvent
désormais qu'on peut envisager pour dire
le les etats-unis ont un accord de
désaccord avec nous la chine désaccord
avec le rabbin je veux dire il ya aucun
première ya une chose dont dans une
prise ce matin qui est assez
intéressante qu'est ce qu'on va parler
de leurs au total c'est la situation du
football anglais
parce que non mais si les liens se
rompent avec l'europe
l'arrêt bosman qui permet d'avoir autant
de joueurs européens qu'on veut devrait
plus appliquée doit être ça sera des
extras
des extra communautaire et donc ils
auront droit à trois ou quatre joueurs
et non seulement le mercato sera
compliqué les joueurs étrangers vont
venir dans les autres pays les droits
télévisés qui sont les plus élevés de
l'angleterre au bc et d'en baisser
c'est une des conséquences possibles
dans le sport la seule bonne nouvelle
pour moi à mon sens c'est que on va voir
ce que ça va se passer parce que ce que
ça va donner
pour le coup ça sera très observé ça
donnera des idées mais finalement cette
idée là il nous tout ça mais il est
parti que ce soit le front national ou
d'autres partis dans d'autres pays ont
déjà à l'idée de vouloir sortir et c'est
un argument de campagne pour eux donc
l'idée ils l'ont déjà en revanche ce qui
serait intéressant c'est d'observer
pendant mon avis ces deux prochaines
années et il en résultera que c'était
une erreur et du coup ça consolidera les
27 à rester ensemble parce que je disais
pas de rester ensemble pour rester
ensemble
il ya des choses à construire est la
deuxième bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il
faudra construire sérieusement une
europe fiscal une europe sociale nord de
l'armée etc
donc ça sera une très bonne chose il
était censé en sort par le haut c'est
une bonne chose par le bas aussi on sait
que c'est une possibilité un commentaire
aussi concernant ce que ce qu'a dit le
journaliste
c'est que je pense pas qu'il faut
divorce faut essayer d'aller vite
pourquoi aussi parce que non mais c'est
vrai parce que il y a des eurodéputés
anglais qui vont voter pour des
législations des lois ou des choses qui
vous concerne ce qui nous concerne plus
donc moi j'aimerai savoir demain
aujourd'hui aux infos comment ça marche
ce sont les anglais pendant deux ans on
est toujours dedans
en attendant d'être dehors mais est-ce
qu'on vote toujours et quel impact ça
peut avoir parce qu'on peut avoir un
vote de blocage
alors je vous propose de voir on va
parler de l'open de france c'est à
partir de 1er
jeudi prochain au 4 juillet et je vous
propose de voir un sujet sur la
préparation du terrain d'abord très bien
pour l'open de france
j - 6 avant l'open de france de golf la
compétition qui fêtera cette année sa
100e édition sera organisée pendant
quatre jours sur les greens du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
parcours totalement remodelée cette
année en vue de la ryder cup 2018 en
coulisses on peaufine les derniers
réglages
il ya encore fort semaine de travail
après tout le travail qu'on a fait il
faut pas oublier quelques l'albâtre cet
effet mais pendant neuf mois
son gros période et l on a fait 125 kg
mais des tranchées pour bien drainé les
parcours forcément de ses 55 km départ
qu il y ait encore de cystine et encore
le travail à faire et une nouvelle il
nous reste mais nous on est on est on
est très près une quarantaine de
jardiniers des centaines de personnes
sont mobilisées dans la logistique pour
préparer cet événement un travail rendu
difficile avec les conditions
climatiques de ces dernières semaines on
a roulé moins d'ego aller plus haut plus
bio de la dernière 105 convenance c'est
vrai que même avec tous les travaux
qu'on a fait le parcours il peut plus se
voiler la quête tourne et on n'est qu'au
l'accès aux mails à la morale d
karine et on est vraiment en ami le
soleil selon les météorologues du golf
national le soleil devrait être de la
partie pour l'open de quoi ravir les
55000 à 60000 spectateurs qui seront
présents sur les quatre jours de
compétition
alors on attendait c'est un derby c'est
super intendant effectivement un jeune
espagnol 30 de ceux qui sont arrivés au
golf national que malgré les pluies
diluviennes qui sont tombées
ben ça ne se voit pas il ya des travaux
d'irrigation raid est formidablement
menée non alors irrigation c'est le ciel
qui fait ça donc on n'a pas arrosé
on n'a pas misé sur tous les travaux de
drainage audrey n'a fonctionné on était
quasiment en fait dans le cahier des
charges la ryder cup qui arriveront u18
une chose qu'on a signés fédération
française de golf c'est de pouvoir après
une pluie d sénat d'ouvrir le parcours
en 3 heures et l'a eue le pire
on a eu juste pour vous donner quelques
chiffres on avait 4 120 mm de pluie
jusqu'au 22 juin du 1er au 22 juin
tandis qu'à moins de juin normale sur
les dix dernières années ces 25 mm 20
fois plus exactement donc c'est donc oui
ça a très bien fonctionné parce qu'il ya
eu ces travaux pendant l'hiver on a été
fermée dit moi c'est ça fait partie de
quelques heures des travaux qui ont été
faits alors et pour cet open de france
est évidemment en vue de la ryder cup
vous vous sentez comment la moins d'une
semaine
non très bien très bien parce que on est
très bien accompagné déjà par par les
promoteurs qui sont fait faire gold
produits prénom avec carriço et
et puis l'europe et un taux qui ont
l'habitude de faire 40 tournois dans
l'année c'est vrai que maintenant
l'embellie qu'on a eu depuis deux jours
et qui va se poursuivre et nous aide
nous aide énormément parce que ça a
l'air bien mais on a des partis quand
même un peu humide et notamment en
dehors des aires de jeux ou les
spectateurs oui entre l'art et le plus
de soucis ou de travail qu'on fait
expects eu aujourd'hui et demain et
jusqu'à l'événement c'est pour le public
c'est un bon moment qu'ils risquaient
sécurité mais aussi qu'ils puissent
venir une hausse entre alors j'ai dit il
ya la perspective de l'arrêt des
attaques ce qui fait qu'il ya un plateau
absolument exceptionnelle c'est vraiment
un début aussi bien pratiquement c'est
vrai c'est exceptionnel c'est une
concordance de deux petits événements
depuis quelques mois qui ceux qui sont
arrivés parce qu'il faut savoir que la
politique de l'open de france a toujours
été pas comme les autres tournois on ne
paye pas les joueurs pour venir et est
donc ce qui s'est passé c'est aux états
unis justement où ils ont placé un
tournoi mondial en même temps que l'open
de france sachant que c'est le 100e sur
le parcours de la ryder cup qui est
quand même
commandez un phare pour leur vingt tours
et quelques joueurs ont décidé en
décliner la possibilité de gagner
beaucoup plus de dollars pour venir
soutenir l'open de france parce que
c'est le centième deuxième plus vieux
tournoi derrière l'open britannique
oui et
et donc en a une dizaine dans ce cas-là
tout joueur on attend 60 mille
spectateurs
c'est un bon cru en effet on peut déjà
dire qu'il ya toujours de la place parce
que c'est un parcours de golf mais les
pré ventes grâce à aux tableaux sont
hausse de 40 % 1 re année donc ça c'est
ça c'est très bon c'est un bon signe en
tout cas la météo
a météo de ce que j'espère il rêve avec
nous et pas trop chaud parce que l'année
dernière si vous rappeler que les deux
extrêmes venaient tous marrant tous
bruns tout dur et 40 degrés l'année
dernière donc non tout tout porte à
l'espoir avoir une très très belle
édition centièmes et vous tiendrez vous
n'êtes pas du tout vous êtes très
décontracté quoi la recherche du site
que parce que je ne sais pas quelle est
pour prendre enfin la compagnie est-ce
qu'il doit devenir esclave oui peut-être
peut-être mais c'est vrai voilà bientôt
je serai plus britannique que anglais et
puis voilà beaucoup de mamans mais non
pour tout cohérent ni calme parce que
j'ai une bonne équipe voilà parce que
voilà vous êtes fière du parcours sur
deux oui parce qu'on a vu la météo les
dix prochains jours je pense qu'il ya
deux jours si on nous avait dit y avait
encore cinq six jours depuis je pense
que on serait entre la corde le pistolet
c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui non non non
d'excellentes équipes c'est aussi la
douzième fois rehaussé au golf national
il ya des habitués qui sont mis en place
on est bien accompagné
le pire qui peut nous arriver
franchement c'est une défection d'un
joueur rendez vous annoncés sur la fiche
ou quelque chose ça c'est le seule
inquiétude sinon on sera prêt le jour j
ai pas problème culturel a peut-être
plus spécialisés mais en devenir un
symbole us open avec des greens qui est
je sais pas une tapée avec une vitesse
absolument incroyable c'est c'est une
norme en vigueur pour les grands
tournois où ça dépend des parcours ça
dépend des organisateurs ça dépend des
parcours ça dépend de la qualité du
gazon malgré tout le tout la pluie qu'on
en a essuyé depuis trois ans parce que
ils ont très très rapide dans la main
ils sont très bons ils sont très sain et
très très bon mieux que l'année dernière
les greens mais c'est le directeur de
tournoi allons nous en avons en jean van
de velde qui est notre directeur de
tournoi est grand ouvert voilà
exactement français et puis en compagnie
de la direction du tour européen de
circuits qui gère qui décide de la
vitesse c'est eux qui vont décider et
c'est nous qui allons impliquer la
vitesse c'est à dire que si le parcours
est trop lent trop dur parce que les
gazons et très épais avec la pluie les
super épée donc on peut perdre la balle
facilement si le parcours en détectent
qu'il est trop dur en dehors des greens
ils vont plutôt les ralentir à dacca
plutôt bien même les arroser moins dure
voilà donc il ya différents choix qui
vont se faire à partir de lundi mardi
prochain avant jeudi
reste à voir absolument oui et c'est ce
que croit savoir un parcours peut
devenir trop dur comme lui à
augmenterait open c'est incroyable donc
mais ce pont c'est un des quatre nageurs
donné on n'est pas un quatre majeurs de
l'année mais on veut surtout du
spectacle c'est l'europe a aussi un
spectacle s'il le prend le trou du
public voir débouler les coûts
voilà vous jouez sur l'arrosage et sur
la taille d'exactement exactement là on
n'arrose pas évidemment les greens
devient dur parce qu'ils sont sur sable
le plus dur est sens plus difficile pour
arrêter la balle est le plus rapide
peuvent devenir les greens c'est à dire
que tout simplement on le temps plus
rares ont fait la honte beaucoup plus
rien deux remarques sur le super
témoignages que vous nous apportez
c'est le premier le premier c'est que
finalement il n'y a pas que le marché
qui régit les lois du sport
j'ai cru comprendre qu'il ya des gens
qui déclinait des rémunérations
importantes pour venir quand même oui ça
nous rassure sa narration mais également
sur les échanges on sait la vérité avec
l'angleterre et d'autres votre nation du
golfe mais par contre j'avais une autre
marque c'est que vous subissez le
réchauffement climatique avec les
extrêmes d'un côté la canicule qui
assèche d'un comté où les fortes pluies
qui sont les vrais conséquences extrêmes
de réchauffement climatique j'avais
juste une question ce que vous pensez
qu'un jour on aura des green synthétique
comme au foot
alors oui parce que sa golf complet
alors en simple clic ses grilles des
gens alors il ya beaucoup de nouvelles
alors dans le candidature on a le temps
là les candidatures de la france sauvée
de la fédération française de relais
pour obtenir la ryder cup
une chose qui nous avaient ya trois
choses qui nous ont fait gagner un
crowdfunding le fait de faire payer les
licenciés de golf la facture au lieu que
ce soit aux sponsors privés ou du risque
de la qualité du parcours l'albatros du
golf national où les joueurs voulaient
que ce soit là et troisièmement le fait
qu'il y aurait une une histoire derrière
tout ça parce que la fédération
s'engagent à créer 100 nouveaux petits
parcours et sur les cendres de vos
pratiques petit parcours jusqu'en 2020
on a fait premier de faire ça on est
déjà 80 essais des parcours de très
courts six ou neuf trous simplement faut
faire débuter les gens et la plupart en
des grilles d'enceinte si nous on vient
de mettre sur le parcours 9 trous cet
hiver loiselet des départs en
synthétique
parce que c'était compliqué d'entretenir
des bises avait tout le monde facile
d'être donné exactement au bout de 20
minutes départ synthétique et on a aussi
maintenant un practice en synthétique
également donc ça vient je pense que ce
ne sera jamais totale parce qu'il faut
de la pétrole pour faire du gazon
synthétique c'est du plastique etc
donc c'est pas nécessairement aussi que
l'eau qu'on pense il faut mieux faire ce
qu'on a fait ouvrir nationale met une
irrigation comme on a fait hyper
performant où on fait 35% de moins de
consommation d'eau avec notre nouveau
système en multipliant par trois le
nombre de têtes de razer donc on a fait
une démarche écologique avec des les
changements qu'on a on a fait
dernièrement pour arroser mieux là où il
faut uniquement et en recyclant l'on
récupère mieux voilà avec le drop est
donc l'écologie n'est pas incompatible
avec l'europe nos droits mais le
problème devrait nous aider plus
qu'autre chose c'est juste là
là on peut pas prévoir à prévoir les
saisons et c'est quand même la nature
est un peu paumé à l'ajout de non pas
évidemment vous pouvez pas me dire si
vous avez un favori pas le droit non
j'ai pas le rencontrer
est ce que quelqu'un va aller parier
mais qui vous allez ce qui vous ouvriez
avec plaisir ah bon on va dire les
français cessent bas je pense pour le
public visé
voilà exactement même si on a des vrais
stars internationaux qui vont cette
année qui vont nous faire un beau public
en angleterre même si ça en angleterre
jour à la télé des choses comme ça donc
on peut espérer avoir des des audiences
plus important qui est bien pour l'image
de la france pour vaincre le golf
national l'open de france un français
pour le public français parce qu'il n'ya
pas de touristes anglais etc qui
viennent voir c'est uniquement un public
local national régional
un français qui gagne dimanche soir
c'est toujours bon pour le service et
thomas levet 2011 dernier en france
c'est dommage mais c'est thomas le vin
festivement effectivement et avant ça et
avec sa double victoire mais on attend
depuis 2011 une victoire française peu
après le très beau couple
donc voilà à partir du 30 juin 30 1er 2
et 3 unis exactement ouvert au public
ouvert au public on peut opérer il y
avait laissé un plat sur place et il ya
de la place pour tout le monde enfin
voilà tout favorisera pas bredouille
exactement et au peu après circuler ce
beau mais en plus c'est très bien fait
pour les gens puissent voir violemment
il ya des exposants il n'y a pas que du
golfe
le vétéran avec les matchs de foot si un
match de foot
sinon c'est aussi retransmis sur canal
oui google + et canal on parle que de
foot
allez parlons un peu de sport angers
mais j'étais abasourdi par le la somme
astronomique de que laurent blanc touche
pour quitter le psg alors ses démentis
par berne à ce qu'est son agent aurait
dit c'est pas vrai du tout c'est pas 22
vignon cellules pour une fois ci pour
les apercevoir ces 21 millions de
clients donc peut-être vol droit des cdd
sa fréquence cdd et simon et vous groupe
et il y avait encore deux pas du métro
dietrich plusieurs mètres c'est le
principe du cdd ils inondent ans madison
ou non va se passer dit il est prêt
évidemment contrat de deux ans avec des
amis qu'il avait menti conjugue ses
principes du cdd dont quand on est si
vous arrêtez le contrant vous devez le
payer jusqu'à son terme le fonds en
l'occurrence est une des clauses les ya
juste quelques mois c'était des risques
et je veux simplement dire qu'on avait
déjà prédit patrice ici à la fin du
match quand il avait perdu donc entre
eux manchester jaster on avait dit ici
en acquérant ce que tous les deux
avaient 10 et j'avais dit qu'on ne
reverrait pas laurent blanc à la rentrée
vous avez tous d'ici six ans il ya pas
de raison on a les images à fait la même
année à tous pas passé loin
on a tous dit il faut revoir les images
mais voilà donc c'est un peu les os et
les lois dans ce sport etc sont les
montants également dans ce sport à ce
niveau ce qui fait ce qui est vrai c'est
que c'était à l'entraîneur extrêmement
bien payée par un tel revers donc la
somme qui lui est doit lui être alloués
beaucoup plus forte que celle des
actions d'abord d'habitude mais sinon
c'est à peu près 22 millions à peu près
l'application des règlements normal tu
es des années qui restent plus si moi je
crois c'est ça qui me 10,3
tadam il était à cette semaine par mois
le confiance a fait de son pays il y a
des joueurs qui touchent plus que ça
encore alors bien sûr certains oui mais
c'est dommage parce qu'en fait il n'aura
jamais été entraîneur puisque zlatan est
en partie maintenant entraîner le psg et
ben il saura aussi leur emploi bon alors
vous laisse moi je voulais parler plutôt
de l'europe à ce que vous disiez qu'il y
aura peut-être des écrans s'il ya des
grands matchs pendant le pont de l'open
de france
et c'est vrai moi j'étais quand même
surpris par l'engouement public pour cet
euro dont ça va je vous regarde la
télévision ça fait des scores le fallait
malgré l'équipe de france aux 14
millions de personnes
les matches qui ne sont pas de l'équipe
de france font au moins six millions de
personnes va il ya un engouement public
formidable ça prouve que les agences
heures enfin tous les annonceurs pardon
ont toujours raison c'est qu'ils savent
que c'est un tel événement un moment
donné les gens qu'on doit être vont être
présents ils seront au rendez vous en
revanche ce qu'on peut dire c'est que ça
a été très lent à démarrer parce qu'on
était tous tous tétanisés par les
problèmes de sécurité
les fans zone s'il faut les faire ou pas
quand le progrès sanitaire a été à
plomber l'ambiance
jusqu'à très tard mais ça a mis du temps
à démarrer mais après une façade
militants devrait pas tellement le
premier concert l'avant 20 la veille du
début il ya quand même 80 personnes
viennent dans la fanzone bien belge en
charge parle pas de la semaine même à
l'ennemi que je vous parle des semaines
aggravant
oui bien sûr on avait la veille c'était
un tout petit on était dedans voir la
semaine avant non je vous parle des
semaines bien avant on n'a pas senti
l'engouement ni dans les clubs de foot
dans dans le mien ou dans ceux dans
lesquels on n'avait pas dans les pendant
les championnats
il y avait à la limite on en parlait par
la seule chose qui intéressait c'était
l'organisation des matchs sensibles
c'est à dire y aura-t-il de la violence
ou pas du hooliganisme
ou pas faut-il des fans zone et c'est
tout a tourné dans nos instances à la
ligue de football par exemple autour du
problème sécuritaire autour des stades
il ya eu un match d'essai 1
galop d'essai puisqu'on est allé au
stade de france ensemble et on a vu
comment la sécurité avait été avancée
pour la finale de la coupe de france
donc ça avait laissé un plaisir est là
pour le coup ça valait le coup de deux
tests de détester voilà donc c'est un
peu plombé avant et puis maintenant
l'engouement est totale parce
qu'effectivement le football draine du
monde la preuve c'est qu'on va drainer
des golfeurs grâce à des écrans géants
au gris on a beaucoup parlé des quelques
abrutis qui se sont battus et cbc les
supporters irlandais qui séduisent
absolument mais la france entière tout
le monde n'a plus que ça lesquelles
celle des irlandais nord du sud sous le
contrôle de notre ami c'est la
république les deux équipes ont des
supports basculer dans les eaux la
technique n'est pas filer vers esambert
et on les voit chanter une berceuse dans
le métro je chantais à la police
ramasser des réparer une voiture qu'ils
ont abîmé sa jeunesse et
l'extraordinaire histoire
je les ai mieux les gars sympa ouais je
les ai vus oskana extraordinairement
beau les supporters
chapeau j'ai vu au stade de france
contre la suède et c'est vrai qu'à
l'extérieur du stade dans l'aude dans le
stade mais on on s'en étonnerait presque
qu'ils soient super man était tous les
tous les supporters que ce soit même
c'est de l'angleterre 2 les causes pays
de galles ont toujours un malade et
surveillant de très grande qualité mais
on a toujours sous-entendu l'idée que le
hooliganisme et britannique mais que
voilà et qui l'a choisi il a exporté la
violence et alors qu'en réalité c'est du
plus récent le prix commencée par ça
mais c'est encore une fois notre cher je
veux mon argent facture wiki vraiment
mis en route le pays ce vers un peuple
est le stade
soyez ça avec la vidéosurveillance tout
ça qu'on a vécu et convient très bien en
angleterre tout le temps vous avez un
anonyme qui est un joueur de rugby s'est
passé des jeunes venus de toulon un oui
et le foot ça vous intéresse alors oui
mais pour les matches comme ça les
grands événements internationaux au
stade les îlots comble terry cela a
suffi de prendre parce que pour l'année
soit ces deux pays non européens et
c'est le petit poucet on aime bien
offrant ces histoires et petits clubs
le petit poucet qui lâche on se connaît
à l'oubli français va soutenir l'islande
et d'une part parce que c'est le petit
poucet d'autre part peut-être parce
qu'il voulait que dit aussi ça peut
jouer ce qui peut s'avérer un nouveau
membre dans lequel histoire remplace
l'anglais les anglais sur les
spécialistes de la compensation
financière je suis pas persuadé que ça
soit une grande compensations en terme
de population et les français vous avez
trouvé comment moi je moi j'adore pour
une raison simple c'est que on n'arrête
pas de dire la france la france la
france ils sont pas là pour produire du
spectacle même si payet a marqué
exceptionnels sont pas la peur de
spectacles en tout cas le premier
quitterait les deux mains vides et on va
dire les deux mais ils sont pas là pour
produire du spectacle sont à prendre à
dire l'efficacité ils font les qualifiés
des qualifs pour gagner ils ont gagné
contrat rempli il ya une stratégie
derrière et je trouve même que y ait une
stratégie peut-être deux on se camoufle
un peu on n'est pas flamboyant et
peut-être que ça va payer on a toujours
gagné quand on organisait la coupe du
monde en organisant la gagner la coupe
d'europe on organise
gagner donc je vous annonce la france et
la france est bien cachée 560 on n'a pas
gagné mais pardon 1960
je vous parle de ça moi je serai à 61 je
vous propose justement sur l'ambiance de
voir un petit sujet sur l'ambiance
pendant le match france- suisse c'était
des yvelines moi qui regardais sur écran
a évidemment un 2 1 pour la france en un
mois 2 0 pour la france 2 1 pour la
france 3 pour la france
les supporters ont cru à la victoire de
la france pour son dernier match de
poule face à la suisse ils sont venus en
nombre au complexe sportif pierre de
coubertin de montigny le bretonneux
suivre la rencontre sur écran géant et
encourager les bleus
ils ont eu l'occasion de vibrer dès la
première mi temps avec les tentatives
françaises une bonne première mi-temps
avec
deux poteaux quand même pour les bleus
donc confiante confiant ça va finir par
rentrer un petit peu déçue mais je suis
positif et je pense que au retour des
vestiaires les bleus perdent la main sur
le match
de l'impatience règne dans la salle
jusqu'à la rentrée de dimitri payet et
sa reprise de volée à la 77e minute sur
la transversale qui réveille le public
score final 0 à 0 les réactions après la
rencontre sont utilisés entre espoirs et
déceptions déçu déçu parce que très lent
petit baballe on sait pas trop il ya eu
deux tirs sur la barre et nous réjouit
c'est un peu c'est tout il gagna contre
la suisse mais après je me demande
qu'est-ce que tout allait mal tisse un
parce que là si c'est pas une petite
compil trop forte c'est pas mal du tout
surtout en première mi temps pas mal de
rythme un petit peu moins en deuxième on
a un peu plus subi mais l'essentiel
c'est de finir premier de la poule et du
coup c'est réussi avec le match nul il
suffisait d'un match nul donc l'aventuré
continue et on sera derrière derrière
les bleus pour le prochain match et les
prochains matches
la france termine première de son groupe
et les supporters pourront continuer à
encourager les bleus dimanche prochain
lors de leur huitième de finale donc
vous êtes apparemment bien compris vous
pariez sur la victoire de la france le 8
juillet florence qui croyait non non on
a préparé une eau non seulement j'y
crois mais je l'espère je le souhaite
selon le terme est viscéralement on est
pour ne voudront pas payer après ça
passera à la france si on est éliminé
comme dans tout bon dieu ma jument bien
longtemps 45 ans le pays de galles est
très étonnant oui un joueur plus un
joueur et dix autres les amanins libre à
ses origines et une équipe de la royaume
uni mais unie réunis n'aurait
franchement je sais que le golf c'est le
seul sport où une équipe européenne
contre l'américain c'est vrai européenne
comptera des requêtes et le savez ce que
disait coluche disait mais je comprends
pas pourquoi on n'a pas une équipe
d'alsace lorraine utile de bretagne et
pas de raison ils ont lire l'homme c'est
pas juste jouer dans le carré final où
on ne rend l'angleterre alors je
voudrais qu'on termine peut-être cette
émission avec cet exploit qui fait
plaisir jean charles lajoie dit qu'il
attendait l'exploit de soleure inpulse
qui s'est posée qui a traversé
l'atlantique on voit de voir un petit
sujet là dessus et puis on en parle
juste après mars 2015
à abou dhabi
c'est un immense et étrange albatros
son envergure de 72 mètres est celle
d'un 747
son poids de deux mille trois cents
kilos et celui d'une voiture familiale
sur tout le corps plus de 17000 cellules
solaires sa puissance est celle d'un
vélomoteur 50 à 100 kilomètres à l'heure
au compteur
il a été construit pour faire le tour du
monde en 12 étapes
le premier tour du monde en avion
solaire
alors ça leur fait une belle saison qui
a traversé l'atlantique qui considère ça
comme un exploit fantastique c'est un
exploit il a dit le pilote picard il a
passé 72 heures sans dormir ces salles
exploit sinon il met deux ans pour faire
le tour du monde
y a rien d'extraordinaire et puis
surtout alors tout le monde est là en
train de dire c'est merveilleux cet
avion solaire qui consommerait rien qu'à
l'arrivée il ya déjà douze camions 50
personnes qui courent pour que l'avion
se fracasse pas au sol pour porter les
ailes on dira un albatros en état en
phase terminale et j'ai envie de marquer
quand on voit après alors le les centres
de contrôle et tout ce qu'il ya derrière
c'est à dire que tout à l'heure notre
ami disait que les green synthétique ce
n'était pas forcément écolo moi je dis
que cet avion je dirais le l'empreinte
carbone quand ils volent et les nuls
mais quand on le fabrique et quand on
suit et quand on voit l ça doit être
dénoncée elle c'est pire qu'une escouade
de b52 donc fait c'est un c'est tout
sauf un progrès
je comprends que ça amuse quand je dis
bah oui c'est rigolo c'est les traces
d'avenir et non je vois pas du tout ça
ne transportent rien sans les instants
il faut que le pilote maigri mais les
premiers avions
bah nan mais justement les premières
heures de grève c'est un retour en
arrière
cet avion ne ne sert à rien mais
vraiment ne transportera rien ne peut
prendre le ler que quand les conditions
météo mais c'est pire que vous pour le
golf c'est à lui de vous faites
attention mais la rose ayadi nuage non
il ya quelques cumulus il ya une tempête
sur l'atlantique il ya ma chochotte ces
terribles ravages en charge c'est aussi
drôle que c'est quelqu'un que son nez
absolue dit oui bien sûr j'aime bien la
démonstration c'est drôle sauf que ils
ne transportent qu'une chose n'est-ce
pas voilà j'avais j'avais le lien
j'avais venir et il transporte
l'investissement pour le futur je crois
que c'est ça qui est important et c'est
vrai que
ce que vous venez de dire là est tout à
fait exact en clair il est en termes
d'empreinte carbone et de consommation
même d'électricité puisque l'électricité
et mais c'est une source de voir mais
voilà on sait très bien qu'il va y avoir
des sauts technologiques qu on va passer
d'un avion qui fait la taille de la 3,80
en termes de voix la et les sauts
technologiques vont réduire les elles
vont augmenter les capacités vont
augmenter la vitesse c'est un peu ce qui
s'est passé quand on est sorti du cheval
mais la chine amateurs les centres
technologiques
non c'est le noir il meilleure des
choses le meilleur exemple c'est moi je
me suis le meilleur exemple un immeuble
le meilleur exemple c'est quand j'étais
petit en l'occurrence je me demandais
pourquoi envoyer une fusée dans l'espace
je voyage je voyais pas l'intérêt de
dépenser autant d'énergie c'est le cas
de le dire pour un mec qui allait se
balader dans l'espace et redescendre on
pouvait faire toute une
une rhétorique autour clairement on sait
maintenant à quoi ça a servi la conquête
de l'espace avec les sauts
technologiques qui vont avec et dans
cette dans cette épreuve c'est ça et
j'aimerais qu'on garde les images s'il
vous plaît jean-charles j'en aurai
besoin un jour comme pour le départ de
laurent blanc je vois les images à la
dernière mission justement d'abord
terminer avec puisqu'on parle t cq de
rire avec pour l'arbitrage est ce qui
est un combat comme ça autres parce que
le matériel de golf s'est beaucoup
améliorée depuis ces dernières années ce
qui est un combat entre justement les
gens qui fabriquent les les
les parcours face à sète ses progrès de
la technologie oui mais c'est très alors
là je vais pas me faire des amis
mais c'est très très marketing ah oui
voilà c'est à dire quand les invente de
nouveaux modèles bien sûr four oui pour
les ordres - merci merci infiniment
d'avoir été avec nous donc je rappelle
le le l'open de france 30 juin 1er 2 et
3 juillet au golf national merci
beaucoup d'être venu à quelques jours de
ses débuts de cet open
merci beaucoup florence faire cas des
merci beaucoup mustapha allaoui merci
beaucoup pour charles johnny et à très
vite pour un nouveau prof